[Musique]
un cadre magnifique pour la soirée
prestigieuse du prix départemental du
mérite
ces personnes qui entrent dans la villa
du département ne sont peut-être pas
connu de tous mais voilà depuis dix ans
c'est l'originalité de ce prix départ
nos compétences nos identifiant dans le
paysage de la société civile différentes
personnes qui travaillent dans l'ombre
qui travaillent souvent péniblement qui
ne demandent rien qui ne se met jamais
en avant et nous notre rôle c'est
justement d'aller les chercher pour les
mêmes pour les mettre une fois en
lumière et il nous faut odeurs alors ce
soir le son à l'odeur je vous souhaite à
tous la bienvenue
chacun son tour partagent une partie de
sa vie de sa passion devant des amis ou
encore la famille comme la maman d'andré
maurice tellement fière de son garçon
carton en chef ailleurs d'aligner ces
noms là dans les lacs intérieurs démence
n'irait me vends mon livre ouvert où les
émotions s'enchaînent les unes après les
autres pour ces hommes et ces femmes de
l'ombre qui méritent de la lumière
ils font tous des choses parce qu'ils
ont des parents des enfants des frères
des soeurs des amis l environnement qui
vous porte aussi la l'énergie elle est
collective
parce que le sens commun ils gardent des
valeurs c'est celui qui vous donne la
possibilité de faire face
c'est comme ils sont pleins d'humilité
que ces lauréats du prix départemental
du mérite partagent leur émotion c'est
le seul prix qui met que je voulais
avoir parce que ça récompense le travail
que j'ai fait pour mon départ
hautmont il est passionnant ce monsieur
s'engage seul le plus de pertes nature à
720 beaucoup de bonheur elles sont assez
brillant ou 200 tickets comme ça j'étais
un petit peu le connaissaient tentation
voilà des gens sont venus m'aider et
aujourd'hui quinze ans après le travail
je suis dans un accompagnement avec un
projet de changer de la société vous la
changer
on peut pas changer de société que par
des mots sont passés par les actes la
soirée s'est conclue comme elle a
commencé en musique mais avec des
choeurs plein de joie et de fierté
[Musique]